For more information, please visit our website at http://www.youtube.com.tr
Max.
Oh, did ya?
I don't know what color it is.
What taste is it?
It's hard tasting.
Max likes cream.
I don't know if she might take one.
Take one?
I'm not familiar with this.
I didn't hear anything.
Heard himself.
How did he?
In the week before.
Yeah.
What'd he do?
Heard himself.
I thought I was going to make a trip to the emergency room.
I injured his neck yesterday.
I hate that sport.
Well, he does.
It's not just watching him.
I even want to watch the other kids wrestle.
I'm like.
Oh.
He's got quite the colorful cake here.
Colorful character.
One for a certain person.
Even you I think you bought it for five or eight.
Three for five.
How's that ice cream, Amanda?
Did you get vanilla?
There's the trick matches, Dirk.
You better get that yellow one in the middle.
Get the long ones, Scott.
It's like your cake.
Dirk, can you burn it?
You're as bad as Alec lighting matches.
You know I'm holding right, that's why I get burned.
This one doesn't want light.
You blew out the candles, Mom!
You did, you blew out that one.
I don't know, I think this cake could take years off for life.
You may have one in the middle, I think it's fueled by kerosene, I believe.
There's two of them together.
Is that it?
No.
Oh.
Oh my goodness, Dirk, get the heat off that thing.
No!
Okay.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Dirk.
Oh, boy.
Nicky burnt yours.
Oh, I chopped the cake.
I'm going to move now.
Do we have a ball girl here?
Can I pull our ball?
Fireball.
Oh, all the candles.
Where's the candles cake at?
There it is.
There we go.
It's very nice.
Individual candles for Grandma.
Yeah.
Anyway.
We don't have that many candles.
Hmm.
No.
There.
Okay.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Grandma.
All right, Kate, it's really good.
This is really good.
Weekend at Fat Daddy's, Friday night back at Blackstown.
Make a difference in the health and lives of the women of Pennsylvania.
We're there for your health, for your community.
Pennsylvania Department of Health, Tom Ridge Governor.
The new millennium is Vertical Horizon.
Vertical Horizon.
JT, Michael, and Mark.
It's pretty grim.
No.
He can't get out.
When he gets out that forest, stick it in front of his legs.
No, because he can get out.
Hold on.
Let's see him jump.
Oh!
What was that?
He heard that bump and he thought something was going giddy.
He looks like an old bear right there.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, just...
He's got this figured out.
You're good.
2001.
Now we are beginning.
Our team is coming up next.
Get ready.
Awesome.
Bubbles and Buttercup.
Mer and Brick.
Dr. Schnur and Stacy.
Are here to save the world.
Pocky Mine.
Do it!
All of them.
Lu-Lu, Lu-Gia, and more.
Rock to music!
Doc, the evil brother.
The evil sister.
Ooga-Ooga.
Voldemort.
Oh gosh, I can't name them all.
So, get ready.
Some of them might be in this episode.
Get re-
We also have a-
We're going to do this whole thing because we're trying to cook a meal for the girls.
Thanks people.
The girls-
Dad, I was just going shopping to, uh, get some food.
Okay, I'll see ya.
But where are the girls?
Where'd they go?
Yeah, I heard they could play.
Uh, uh.
Just a bit.
Not that I'm a junk man.
Uh-oh.
I'm charging it.
Don't be mad at that when you need something.
Dad, Dad.
My cable?
Something to shake the A.C.?
This year's an issue, say, today, Stacy.
A.C. parts?
I'm just about to-
Here's a picture of the A.C.
Not.